Ian: In Marvel's latest
movie, Brie Larson steps into
the role of Carol Danvers
in "Captain Marvel."
Like many Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies,
"Captain Marvel" gave us not one
but two post-credit scenes.
Let's take a look at what we saw.
Oh, and obviously, spoilers ahead.
The first post-credits scene takes place
at some point after the events
of "Avengers: Infinity War."
After Thanos completes
his Infinity Gauntlet
and eliminates half of
all life in the universe
with a snap of his fingers,
the remaining Avengers
are left to pick up the pieces.
Here, we see Captain
America, Bruce Banner,
Black Widow, and War Machine
all out of costume in a room together.
They look at a small beeper
that flashes Captain Marvel's logo.
If you'll recall from
the post-credits scene
at the end of "Infinity
War," Nick Fury sends out
a distress call to Captain Marvel.
It rings as he turns to dust.
What other heroes could the Avengers
be trying to call for help?
We know that Ant-Man somehow
escapes the Quantum Realm
and ends up in "Endgame"
as he's present in the
movie's first teaser trailer.
Ant-Man: Ant-Man? Ant-Man,
I know you know that.
Ian: During this post-credits
scene, the signals go
blank, then suddenly
Captain Marvel pops up.
"Where's Fury?" she asks
before the scene cuts to black,
seemingly unaware of what Thanos has done.
This post-credits scene is a
great teaser for "Endgame,"
but it also leaves us with
a lot more questions than answers.
"Captain Marvel" takes place in the 1990s.
When and where was Captain Marvel
when she got Fury's distress signal?
Was she leaping through time and space
when the Thanos snap happened?
Now, it's no secret that Captain Marvel
will meet up with the surviving
Avengers in "Endgame."
And no, we don't get to meet
any new characters in this scene.
But getting to see Carol Danvers
in the same room with them is a huge deal
and a long time coming.
Nick Fury: Oh, oh, you wanna get personal.
Ian: Following in the
footsteps of a few other Marvel
movies, the second post-credits
scene in "Captain Marvel"
is more of a gag, well, a literal gag.
In the first Avengers, the
second post-credits scene
features the gang eating shawarma
to reward themselves for saving the world.
Iron Man: You ever tried shawarma?
There's a shawarma joint
about two blocks from here.
I don't know what it
is, but I wanna try it.
Ian: The second end-credit scene
of "Guardians of the Galaxy"
featured a cameo from Howard the Duck.
The second post-credits
scene in "Captain Marvel"
gives a platform to Goose,
the movie's scene-stealing
feline who we also find
out is an alien lifeform.
Fury: Aren't you the cutest little thing?
Ian: Goose's most dangerous
weapon is a pair of
tentacles that pop out of his mouth,
capable of swallowing humans whole.
At one point, he also
swallows the Tesseract,
which has been an object of
intrigue for many characters
throughout the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
During "Captain Marvel," Nick Fury
takes quite a liking to Goose
even though Goose took Fury's eye out,
which is a drastic change from how
Fury lost his eye in the comics.
In the comics, he lost his eye
from a grenade in World War II.
In this scene, Goose jumps
up on Nick Fury's empty desk.
At first, it feels like we're about to see
a post-Thanos world,
similar to what we saw
during the end credits of
"Ant-Man and the Wasp."
This scene shows Goose slowly but surely
coughing up the Tesseract.
So clearly, this is set not long
after the events of "Captain Marvel."
The Tesseract serves an
incredibly important purpose.
It holds the Space Stone.
During its history, it has been possessed
by a wide array of characters.
In "Captain America: The First Avenger,"
Red Skull briefly holds it.
Howard Stark then locates
it deep in the ocean
at the end of that same movie,
in the wreckage of
Captain America's plane.
In "Thor," it's in SHIELD's possession.
Loki briefly gets it in
the first "Avengers."
Most recently, it was
in Thanos' possession
along with the rest of
the Infinity Stones.
Between the time Stark has it
to the time Nick Fury has it,
it somehow ends up on Mar-Vell's ship.
A lot of people thought that Jude Law
would be playing Mar-Vell,
a Kree spy sent to Earth,
not Annette Bening.
How did she get the Tesseract?
Is it possible that she worked
with Stark on a project,
maybe involving light speed,
and she was entrusted with the Tesseract?
But again, we're left with
more questions than answers.
Fury: That's a yes or no question.
Carol Danvers: Yes.
Ian: Overall, the second scene is really
just there for fun.
It's a reward for those who keep watching
after the final credits.
So there you have it.
That's what happened during the two
end-credits scenes in "Captain Marvel."
Was there anything we missed?
Let us know in the comments.